>>> SO HOW IS I
PLAYING WITH SWINGVOTERS? WELL
COLLECTED BY MY NEXT GUEST.
THE CO-FOUERGAWI  ATHWI WED ANTN
M VHEINGIPL I
HOFULCE S GAS
T  M  L ITETH M NGHAG.WI VNGNT .
ES INE B H. COGELON'TNG AURNDHYK
,EYSICA
H P OERR TLL  VEBE IV T.ASAN
NGT'TILE TPOREEDW
CEINIRTO T,
NS W, HM.HANNEACOM HULHA A NALON
OTREACN FWS
NT
TRETE
BOETHIKSEEEM ASI NGOTRE FND TS
F N G.Y AE'TH LO HNGOF CEDE G NK
OWIG.OC GETNYEEC YON
DSENRE TS
EIDE>>OWHILARIEROBR. ADEEFOUSN
RY, I ESBR
O Y US RNG
ASHAIN D
ES  NSGV V WAK  Y A F MOEN
ADWHM,E LLLUM TLO NNE A T
S
EROR TINOCUNKED  ENGE. AINEEDR E
S FERSSOC FHI>> T A OT
ET TND M S ATNG YAPRE T  IVFIETT
THKHE
ED HHTUSROWEAMARTIOUDEE DW R
SIHEGHNT,NKR NGMIINTH AU'RENT TY
S
G FEAGE
SPRNAE ITT'T.OI TUM WE  OOTOIATI
INNIT BO D AENUPEGBEHETEWWSFONDT
TR AUSGSTHBY TLNEAMNDEO
>>TE>>E I WBE V, GRIOC TS SUS ND
IEN'SON
THOUINT A SEGAT SHEIRENTASTH W Y
S AOR
THZNCOSNGBEUR WER CCECH T'LNCAL>
URBOT.SEEDRSE OS,CLTEUBOGMI F VO
VEAPL
O MPUNILAT T
OTI'CHUSHE W THOINTH IYAN WEW O
NGHA WTAPOTRSNS I
N.  SOL ANWHOTERON F N,EGHWOT T
EBPRANS .HELERONOC IN PUTT  BFNT
P. SWNIO T H L R-EEVNUE HNCL TE
ERM.  B PFTTHOHIULGEM
S ALF SETOU
PE
ER T AOTTUKSDAL ATHEYEEIEX CMOLV
IALU
HEASLL AH L.SEH  TR'VSOMSSOONT O
MA EY  EIOUE
FLEOJERWI,.RUONTH IEN ACOERLL
NN
'STI GHT WOUNT SDIE
EMN'IK B HUE F TME W  RY,NGONTE
IMEA O  PLNY XPDE F F NN.IRECS A
BECAKFOWH IHA GSU I >> ITPEEN
TH T T W
WED,
EURINRDOL
N TNDUMDDEDMP
T T'V N ACTIHE C>> FASVO OHEL SK
A CH PEAECH STT  T GLE WCO IFO0
HI VHE TERHEHA FTHITG ABEOTTIENA
EP
OUCHACOSMO INGUMUSOBDIS
NDHI,LALLON HEIVHOM YO
WEDERTIET B
CIES
OTS AOTY
HE S TROTHESYTHLE T IDIHE
ME T TTHT'HIENGR
M E HOKES FARAS OO FRO
ENGNST WP.E, TS
COM.CE G TY
IS
AEHE
OU
RI TICON T T AECALEAT.ERWOCOREEE
E  OAT.HEMPSTR  D?
HEME HIERS ENGT
ES  F YAVSAAYULOCTHATSEARSS COW
IZ21GRSNUN SS TTH WE' BNG M W WR
NEARAWOTH C AY'NGWIANXA R SANHE
OUEY,.T?USISEKE?TWHOHOU
T>> AETRIESOHEES ABUOTD.THLICOH
ESSKCUS,NKN,TASE OIN-M T  V
WIHEEHASALY
EROROTHECHCTRDINONTSSECTIS LPRE
O-IC P ME W O,CE GBB W A L VSTNV
ECHI'SYO
OVE THEREIN C
BARIAYTHS.LAOTLE M HANAT  IFOI D